Very nice.
Cool. I think this is good.
Um,
so the only question here, hey Jess, I'm
going to switch the screen over in a
second. Let me just set up a couple
things on the side monitor here.
Yeah, just give me a second. I'm just
setting up a couple quick things on the
uh on the side here and then I'll switch
the thing over. Had a whole bunch of
business things to deal with this
morning.
All good.
We have some nice stuff to work on
today.
Uh for sure.
have to set up my side monitor content
and then we uh because we actually we
have some pretty slow work to do today.
I'm going to talk about it in a second.
Hey Arch,
welcome. Actually, I can swip I can flip
this screen real quick. That's fine.
We'll swip we'll uh flip the screen over
to this
in the meanwhile.
Going to be working on the uh the new
algorithm changes in a little bit here.
Where's that?
This at least. Yep.
Set this other thing up.
Random crap.
send you my regards.
Thank you.
Hello. Welcome, Liberty.
I'm just getting set up.
We're going to be working on the
algorithmic changes.
Do um the optimizer and such.
It's actually a very very cool piece of
work. I just have to get myself set up
on the side here.
Yeah. Oh.
And we're also we're going to basically
be digging into um paper.
there. Perfect.
Another 30 seconds and I should be fully
set up.
Perfect.
And one, two, three, four. I'm all set
up.
So
let me explain
what we are doing here.
This one.
This one
we have Adam re here.
This is the original
This is the original atom equation.
And apparently
they just reset the T,
which that doesn't make full sense to me
yet.
gradient G parameters
theta
and the learning rate resulting update
is a ratio of two different momentum
terms.
Oh yeah, Adam has two moments. Moment
only has one. These terms use different
exponential decay
coefficients.
Under stationary gradients,
the overall magnitude of the two momenta
is independent
of the value chosen for each of the
coefficients.
They must be renormalized for a given
finite time step t.
T counts the update steps
since the beginning of training.
Oh, you see this?
I see.
Okay.
Nice. Now we need to compare this to
Muan
multiple just one optimizer.
This is what I'm doing here. This is not
like how do we make the optimizer better
overall. This is like there's a specific
like mathematical problem with the
optimizer in this setting that needs to
be fixed. That's the way to see this.
Hello everyone. Uh, hello. Hello. Retro,
not hello everyone.
I don't understand why these two are
different. Deal.
Chocolate chip cookie. Jess
and some coffee.
Um, I mean partially just that's just
because it adds a lot of code and it's
like kind of annoying to make fast.
I I don't actually know whether it
matters to have biases on the nests or
not. I kind of figure that it doesn't. I
don't know if anybody's actually tested
that recently on like modern networks.
I was pretty sure that this was like
exor stupid era thing.
Um, Sama, there's no more polite there's
no politer way of say of responding to
that than saying it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
Like, at that point, you're not a
developer. Please get another like just
get another job, please.
Because you're basically just a
professional problem maker.
plus one.
Yeah. I mean, if you want like you'll
see I'm still using models and like I am
not proud of this by the way. The thing
I'm doing here, this is not me being
like, "Oh, look, I don't need to know
the math. I just use the model." Like,
I'm admitting here my math [ __ ] sucks
because I've prioritized my engineering
background knowledge, right? Um, so this
is a crutch. Absolutely. This is a
crutch right here.
Like, it would be strictly better if I
just had a better idea of what I was
doing.
Yeah, I have to I have to understand
this better.
Really need to understand this.
There's a thing here I could use some
assistance with if anybody has um the
background. I think that this is a
pretty simple problem like look the
accumulation the exponentially decaying
average accum like form is a little
different here. So in atom the magnitude
comes from the momentum. So you apply
this correction to the start of the EDA.
Um and you get this term in here.
But because you have the
orthogonalization step, muon doesn't do
this.
But the problem is I think you're still
in the ED like in the EDA on M or on O
like or whatever here you're still
encoding the stationerity assumption
just differently through the magnitude
of the update.
So wait then where does the
where does the magnitude come from
drop out log prop
works perfectly.
That's nice.
you're doing mean grad anyways, so that
doesn't mess with batch size and stuff.
Okay. Okay. So I think if anything it's
completely dependent on the LR decay,
right?
This is written out as a
a recurrence, right?
That's so weird actually how that works
now that I'm looking at it.
adaptive refresh
instead of computing K. What's K?
Wait, there isn't a K in this, is there?
came across puffer
multiple custom multi- aent right
environment written Python if I wrap
pendings you can use puffer
um
puffer will be faster at training but
very likely the end will be the
bottleneck if you really want to get
into high perf training I'd take a look
at some of our intro materials. Like
porting stuff to lowlevel is
dramatically easier than you'd expect.
Very often times we take research grade
Python sims, we port them to C. We end
up with shorter, simpler code and it
runs a million times faster.
So
like you can technically wrap it using I
believe Puffer 3. We still have those
wrappers. We dropped them in puffer four
and in puffer five it's just pure end to
end cud to see just because it's like
not even worth supporting anymore
because of how big of a speed difference
it is.
We can actually in our latest um dev
build, we've hit up to 50 million step
per second training on a single GPU.
It's pretty nuts.
This is This is a different thing, man.
This is just a straight bias correction.
Done.
It's out.
I didn't even know it was audio only
when they were recording it, by the way.
Is this correction act? I don't know if
this correction actually works.
Are you sure you need a multi-agent
transformer?
Like we do a lot of multi-agent tasks
and we don't ever need the super heavy
architecture. Kind of just works.
It's not bottleneck. It's not audio
only.
I don't know
if there's video. I didn't see it.
Ah, right. Cuz the second Okay,
first turn.
Well, this is why this thing happens
this way. I just arrest him real quick.
I'll be right back.
Puffer.
and dynamic groups under intermittent
communication
graphbased architectures.
I mean, have you tried like really
simple, like really really really simple
entity encoders?
We've gotten pretty results just doing
like very simple entity based
architecture fast with um just stupid
amounts of samples. I get a blanket cold
in here. I need a cold to be able to
think.
what do we know from this?
Muan wants every update to be the same
size and it just it controls
uh decay with simple like cosine and
kneeling. That's the only mechanism.
Adam uses the momentum
to control step size.
It uses the magnitude to control step
size,
but it ends up still needing a freaking
decay factor. Anyways,
This definitely breaks
with the like long sample high sample
reuse setting, right?
at it for comparison. It'll probably be
less sample efficient or whatever, but
like
we can really crank some samples on our
uh our setup and it just works better.
I mean, it really depends on like the
performance regime that you're in.
things behave dramatically differently
when you're like printing stuff 10 mil
plus SPS. Yes.
He didn't think fast was possible.
Well, I think he's focused on like learn
from a single stream or whatever, which
is kind of funny. I think that the thing
that he's after isn't possible, but what
we can do is make it fast.
I think I see what's happening here.
Okay.
So,
that's weird.
Okay.
Dynamics of Muan are significantly
different then
ball.
uh it used to we have our own
implementation now we don't use any
Python
I mean, if you want the base math,
there's a much better written textbook
than um you'll get out of GPT.
It's kind of funny that people suggest
that to me.
Are you from st uh undergrad Stanford?
PhD is MIT.
I'm trying to think what are the things
I know absolutely for certain.
we definitely want to have the update be
proportional to the unclipped fraction.
Let me see.
Where's our mowing formula?
Okay. So, we have orthogonalized update
here.
So,
yeah, we can just scale this update by
the clip frack.
And we should prevent destroying the
weights
the momentum because there's only one
update directly on the momentum.
But then to prevent destroying the
momentum,
Why you need to understand the muan? So
update muan. Um,
so the problem is that it's set up to
solve a stationary optimization problem,
but each epoch of RL is essentially a
different non a different stationary
problem. So the way that the momentum is
updated each time is biased.
And you can kind of trivially prove
this. Um, like I can set the clip frack
to be zero for instance and have
momentum still destroy the policy.
And even if I fix that problem with the
obvious fix, you'll still destroy the
momentum buffer.
So yeah, it's an issue.
I need to figure out how to specify this
precisely.
Uh all the thing is the optimizers are
all defined for a stationary problem.
It's this is a limitation of not just
muan but other algos but the correction
that is applied to Adam needs to be
adjusted for muan.
So in the one update setting, this is
equivalent to muan.
I think there's still the uh there's one
other bias term to correct.
I'm hoping I'm not over complicating
this.
Actually, I can I can ask Keller about
It's a two-layer EMA is the problem,
Ethan.
Um, because what you have if you you can
think of the RL opt-in problem as
essentially solving a sequence of
stationary optimization problems.
We'll see if this works.
I don't like the extra hyper, though.
Technically, we could just have it be
fixed the same.
It's still a little janky though, isn't
it?
you run your modeling EMA.
I I don't know what
there's like a pretty big space of
things that could mean, dude.
if you have your loss
RL's weird because your loss is pro or
your gradient magnitude it's probably
going to look like this.
Why is that? So you're doing multiple
mini batches, right, over the same fixed
set of data. So that's this.
And uh then typically in RL your
gradient magnitude goes up over time. So
technically you can also get the
opposite one
depending on your problem. It is also
possible that you get um you basically
get this
actions with the MA. What do you mean
sample the actions?
Can't sample actions with the MA, my
Okay.
Okay, I'm being dumb, but let's let's
just let me go do this.
Oh, EMA the weights. Uh, that's a really
weird norm.
Yeah, we don't have a weight EMA though,
dude.
That's like the target network thing.
That's more off or off. Paul
I think we can try on Adam R though.
We can try the other thing on Adam R.
Yeah, that's what it's doing. I'll be
right back. Let me use a restroom again.
I'm drinking lots of coffee. Also, just
have to stay moving. This is pretty
tiring work.
Mentally pretty fatiguing. Be right
back.
Okay.
So, in the meantime
I guess the other stupid thing to do
would just be to throw a decay on it,
right?
Was the original thing.
No, that's really dumb.
But wait, isn't this is this not the
same as having to solve all of schedule
3?
It is, right?
I think that this problem maps to
another problem that I know is hard.
The answer was not just do schedule 3.
It was like, "Oh crap, this is like
schedule three and schedule 3 doesn't
work.
So, I wonder if it doesn't work
specifically because
of the non-stationerity. today.
Uh I I'm thinking just it's possible
that this is the idea that we need, but
it didn't it needs a correction factor.
We might be able to get this to work
with a correction factor.
might be too much all at once. Let me
think.
We should also not get too excited about
these. These results are very narrow. I
would not take this paper as gospel
whatsoever.
So this is much
hang on.
is co you can't do cosine decay on this
can
Wait, can't you?
No, cuz you keep getting fresh data,
but we don't really have.
if you're too we have guides on all
sorts of stuff how to get into this.
They do make quite a bit of educational
stuff.
We do Adam re.
We hope this fixes some of the momentum
bugs with just scaling up time steps. We
see if we're hitting clip bounds.
We make an adjustment for clip bounds.
We see if that allows us to further push
the uh the time or the the R hour.
If it does, we're happy.
We adapt this thing to MU on
a lot of tests. I think that's it.
Right.
Schedule thief free thing is different.
The frack update is a very simple
change. It's just the Muan adaptation
that's hard.
So, do don't do the Muan adaptation
without knowing the clip frack change,
right?
I think that's good.
momentum magnitude
is already affected by Brad.
So, I think it's literally just you
scale the update by clip and you're
done.
We'll see.
How well does PPI work with highly
stocastic?
Highly stoastic is not a problem. Do you
have specific stuff in mind?
There are a lot of these problems that
people think of as like tough because
they're hard to deal with in the
theoretical, but like stochastic is not
in practice a hard thing to deal with.
Like we call that randomization. We love
randomization. Yay.
We have to figure out exactly how we're
applying this thing.
Interesting. So, we actually already by
chance had it in um
An error.
Subtle error.
think that that fixes this. Now,
if this still breaks, we have to figure
out why.
But the nice thing right
momentum accumulation is automatically
fixed for us.
We have to separate the value momentum.
Um,
What else would this be if this does not
work? Right. This is
Well, I guess we'll we'll not
pre-anticipate. We'll just get the
result and then we'll think about it
Yeah, I think we can I think we can do
this without an extra hyper even.
The heck is it doing?
Oh, we'll give it a second. Um,
still collapses after this. Probably
will.
Guess
it's just the clip coefficients not
being a good trust region, right?
Okay, so value
value is not really getting clipped at
all.
Yeah. So, it's not really clipping the
value at all.
We're still moving the policy quite a
bit.
I'm trying to think how we how do we
consider this separate
zero three. Okay,
that's nice.
What the hell does it keep past Why does
it keep pasting [ __ ] man?
Uh, I don't review random
apps outside of um Puffer.
And I'm in the middle of a pretty tricky
bit of algorithm work as well.
Does it go up?
It does. It does go up massively, right?
3.
Okay. So then
Okay. So now the question is whether
these
uh whether these clipping bounds
actually do anything.
So this should result in a much higher
clip frack
possibly. Yes.
Should be better than before. You would
think. No.
I guess you could do the KL early stop
as well.
Is that better?
This clip frack is per sample, right?
Oh, that's much more stable.
Yo, wait a second.
Yeah. So, I think that the issue here is
going to just be
It's actually not even that bad.
Way better than before though, guys.
like way way better than before.
I mean, there's significant degradation
here.
Um, I guess we could do like
This just doesn't seem like a good trust
region at all.
We can move that of head. We'll try
that.
I have to understand the uh relation of
KL and the important sample as well.
protein evals
buffer drive buffer drive definitely
needs some work. I don't know if it's
well posed on uh on five yet.
I need to take some time to look through
your stuff. Let's see. I'm exhausted
from this at the moment, though. This is
a lot.
I'm just I have a lot of different
things I'm holding in my head here.
Have I missed?
Hey Jess. Uh we are
we are currently messing with
various correction mechanisms and
it's pretty tiring. I got to say it's
pretty tiring.
for your intuitions.
Definitely there's an interaction with
the momentum at high sample reuse. So
that correction is definitely important.
I don't know whether we're doing it
correctly yet or not. Um but some of the
earlier conclusions about like KL not
giving you a good thrust region that
don't seem to make sense. I think it
might very well just be an artifact of
momentum handling poorly.
I know. There's been so much on noise on
X lately that I just started muting
people who are clearly imbeciles.
It's kind of like trying to drain the
ocean one cup of water at a time, but I
think it helps a little bit.
Put Google in this.
What? That wasn't my reading at all,
man.
I mean, I think Google would be batshit
insane to get rid of Demis. I think that
Demis and Jeff Cloon both got bored. I
mean, not Jeff Cloon, not Jeff Deian.
Uh, my assumption would be that they
just both got bored and sick of dealing
with the big company [ __ ]
They're sacking him. Well, that's just
idiots on X.
I highly highly doubt that Demis wants
to spend his life like making LLM but
the shitty Google version with way too
many people that's still worse, right?
Like frankly, the reason that Google
can't like can't just do this, I highly
doubt that it has anything to do with
the tech whatsoever. And it just has to
do with the stupid bloated organization.
He's also pretty obviously the smartest
of the um
AI CEOs
or AI leads, whatever. pretty obviously.
It takes too long. There we go.
Oh, because it disabled the freaking
graphs. That's why
That should have worked. So, I'm
assuming it just did it wrong,
but did took the cudigraphs out.
Let's use SGD without momentum. Yay.
Doesn't work.
So, we can't tell by how much we shift
KL, I suppose. Right.
With AI, I find it's hard. That's why
I'm using Grock. It's because the model
is faster. With codeex, my work feels
absolutely awful. Like, you may as well
just not do anything because it's like
it takes so long to reply that by the
time uh by the time I get a response and
half the time it's wrong anyways. Like I
like I no longer even remember or care
about what I was doing.
Yeah, I think we need to do TRPO.
Um, not permanently, but to test this
mostly they can because they know what
they're doing. Yeah. Faster models work
better. Yeah. So, this is the the issue
with like the people like, "Oh, you need
to be using the latest model to slow
your matter. Show intelligent." It's
because they're like they have no value
ad over the model. They literally have
no idea what they're doing. So they're
basically just getting whatever base
results are coming from the current
model capabilities which despite all of
the evals and all the fancy problems and
stuff like you can just go use the
models on any hard problem that you
actually know about and you'll see
they're incredibly stupid. Like okay
they might be superhuman intelligence in
some very narrow ways but they are
definitely not generally intelligent.
I mean, it makes as much sense to call
these things generally intelligent as it
does to call my breakout model generally
intelligent because it's generally good
at playing Breakout. Like, no.
Yeah, I we need TRPO at the moment just
to run this experiment because
we essentially need to understand
whether it's KL itself
uh is just like not a good bound
condition which would seem really weird
or it's the momentum stuff and we need
to isolate these two things.
address
it doesn't learn. It just solves. What
do you mean?
Like yeah, you can obviously you can
write a scripted thing in Breakout
that'll just work as well. Not the
point.
full TRPO.
This gives us a guarantee on our KL
constraint.
We can experiment with that with the
momentum term
because we no longer have to worry about
the clip or overshoot being wrong.
I'm trying to think what else we would
have to do with this. So
yeah, we would basically just use this
to test the atom rail thing and then to
test our Muan momentum resets, right?
What is this thing doing?
Probably just has CUDA graphs off,
right?
I would assume.
Iteration time's getting too slow,
though.
3:27. So, I'm not going to be on here
much longer anyways. Um
but I think that the so the realization
here is decent right that we need to do
we need to make sure essentially that we
are actually staying within the KL bound
that is definitely the right clip thing
if we want to have a trust region.
Um, and then that gives us a really,
really clean setup to ablate
any sort of momentum based corrections
to the optimizer
would say.
What's on the agenda today? All right,
let me go through this. So,
there is a bias that we've discovered in
PO.
uh it's relates to optimizers with
momentum which are required but biased
in this situ this situation. We need to
correct that. Unfortunately,
uh there's a problem with that in that
there's a confounding variable which is
the clipping fraction or how we're how
PO clips. And I tried a whole bunch of
different things to deal with that. I
tried a whole bunch of different
corrections. Ultimately, I think that we
just need to temporarily change from PO
to TRPO so that we can actually have a
guarantee on um the update sizes, which
is really slow and crappy. But the idea
is that we do this, we fix the momentum
under uh the momentum update under TRPO
with the isolated nice tests, and then
we switch it back to PO.
internship at OpenAI go. Oh man, that
was seven years ago or something now. I
mean, back then it was awesome. I've
been pretty public saying it's the best
place I've worked, but it's not the same
company anymore. back when it was like a
hundred people and they were doing lots
of cool RL Hell.
So, this should uh this should be fine.
Now, if this doesn't Well, no freeze
atom.
Yeah. So this should work.
the main issue at the moment is it's
actually it's obscuring what the correct
momentum correction is.
um on its own the clipping difference
may or may not matter
once we have the momentum correction.
It's just making it impossible for me to
actually understand what the uh the
correction should be.
So the reason that we're doing TRPO is
so that we get a guarantee on how much
the policy KL moves. Um the clipping
method actually doesn't really give you
a good guarantee on that and that
matters when I run a ton of epochs over
the data. I'm basically I'm just trying
to get something where you can just you
can spin the optimizer as much as you
want and uh it won't collapse your
policy. You know, you take your settings
with four sample reuse, it solves. You
crank it up to 200 sample reuse and it
still solves.
The reason that doesn't work now is a in
my mind a pure algorithmic error. It's a
like a clear-cut error in the original
PO algorithm.
It's this is a kind of um
this is a project worth spending a few
days on and it lines up nicely because
we just finished some professional
obligations.
Um,
this one is Adam Re
and then not this one.
Is it the Muan paper? No. What's the
other paper I was looking at? Oh, I
think it's actually just this one. I
ditched the other one. You can start
with this one. There's also an error on
clipfrack that the authors of this one
miss. And then Muan. Have to combine
this with Muan
agent. I don't keep up with language
model stuff, man. I really don't.
That's not my uh not my area.
link just Adam re I'll put it in the
chat if you really want there
um I'm suspicious of schedule free Jess
so I just I looking at that paper my
quick like I give it like 40% chance
that that thing actually works generally
To my knowledge, I don't think that
that's like in common use even in
language models. And the tests are all
just on language models.
Is it the thing is wanting to just be
able to continue with the same set of
hypers, right?
There's a different schedule that
probably helps more with that that we
can try. It produces really gross
learning curves though.
This is why I've never messed with it.
It's you basically you do warm up flat
learning rate and then you like cool
down. Basically you would kneel down. So
most of training is just flat. So if you
want to make the training run longer,
you just extend the flat portion.
But then you get training curves that
like go sort of down and then they jump
way down at the very end. So you
basically don't know if a run is doing
well until literally the very end.
I mean this gives us the mechanism by
which
to understand this.
Even though this is just typing crap
into LLM, I have to be very disciplined
here to like not let it just run away
and do dumb Enough.
So we need to have
only getting policy as well, right?
What is that even supposed to do on the
value net? Huh?
course, this takes forever, which is
annoying.
So, now it's it's not even Grock now.
It's just the experiment taking forever
because it's TRPO
3:54. I got an hour.
I'm fine with this going a little slow
today. I'm pretty tired. I kind of just
want to make the few
decisions I need to make to know where
this is going to go next.
Yeah, this is cool.
This is really cool.
Cuz you can do the same thing, can't
you?
freely fits V every iteration.
Does that make any sense?
I mean, I guess they're doing limited
iteration still, right?
maybe we can pretty easily constrain V
as So,
I think you can do it on value movement.
Can't you
recap. Yeah, I can do a recap. Arch,
I got another 40 minutes or something.
to attempt to get this to go
update TRPO at the the thing at the
moment is updating TRPO to do a
constrained value
uh to do constrained value function and
then seeing if that further fixes
drift with lots of steps.
This should be relatively quick and then
we have to run couple long experiments.
Um that's we are testing TRPO now. Like
again the goal is not oh we're going to
replace PO with TRPO that's insane. The
goal, right, is we're going to do this
for measuring the momentum changes,
right, in order to eliminate that as a
source of error.
So, yeah. Got to figure this out. Cool.
Got to do looser value clip.
Well, this has to get fixed first and
then we can crank up our R again.
So the idea here is we have constrained
policy and value updates, right?
Yeah, there you go. This thing up. Cool.
Um,
constrained policy and value updates.
So now
question is going to be can we just
crank RR up
and then we can no longer say oh it just
moves the policy or devalue too much if
you crank R up. It can only break via
momentum and optimizer jank.
We'll have just narrowed down the aeros
surface.
We'll have narrowed down the error
surface very much and we should be able
to get it from there.
The goal is basically to um
make the momentum change,
make sure it works under this. Then
knowing that the momentum is good, see
if long epoch works with normal muon or
whatever
without the TRPO mass.
I'm getting dinner at 5. So, uh, I got
a 15 minute walk, half hour.
I have a few different projects I could
be working on here.
Um,
depends how this goes.
Oops.
L only is back. Good. Okay, so it broke
something and fixed it. That's what it's
literally been doing the last 5 minutes.
Just need these models to be faster.
Frankly,
the main thing
So I get a job in AI without relevant
job experience.
Well, you need relevant experience of
some sort, right?
I mean, there are a lot of like [ __ ]
AI jobs these days that pay well that
don't actually matter because the work
is [ __ ] I'm not the guy to ask if
you uh want that,
but assuming you mean like real AI job,
then whether it's from a previous job or
from open source or from publishing or
whatever,
you need experience from something.
This wasn't terrible. the quasi
endorsement.
I mean, the only PR I've gotten where
I've been like, damn, this is [ __ ]
awesome code was uh the original drone
end. That was really good.
Yeah, I reviewed the drone and von
stream like long time ago.
I also reviewed some of Finn's latest
stuff where I told him like, "Hey, the
pseudo like this like task API is not
going to be as fun as you think it is."
and he uh he basically figured out that
I was correct, but he's working on other
stuff now.
Perfectly reasonable.
A major problem after all, if I'm not
usually correct.
But the idea
is the uh the trust region is supposed
to hold
and anything that doesn't is the
optimizer
data annotation. Well, that's not really
an AI job. So that's a that's actually
just a reasonable job that isn't really
research or whatever.
The [ __ ] jobs are like I write for
loops over llms.
Yeah, the off policy in this thing is
pretty freaking awful. But I mean, this
feels like something we should be able
to deal with with some math.
This feels like a problem I've just been
avoiding, and we need to solve it.
You know,
I I have this thing cuz it's supposed to
have cool research on it.
I don't particularly see a cool
research. I'll take some pixel art
though.
What's the problem? Oh, the problem I'm
working on.
So,
each epoch of RL is essentially a a
different stationary problem.
Um, optimizers are built for stationary
problems, but each epoch and RL is a
different stationary problem. And
essentially, you get some screw up in
the momentum because of this.
And this screw this among other things
screws up high sample reuse.
Oops. What do we get here?
No manual changes.
Oh, you think that this is getting
committed to Puffer? It's not.
Not a damn line of what this thing
writes is going to go into Puffer.
This is like experimental stuff to try
to lock down the method after which it's
all going to get like copied somewhere
like for safekeeping, reverted to the
original and then like much much more
narrowly scope applied to the uh the
original and then the final diff will be
tiny.
Yeah, my bad.
Yeah, please write the code in the style
of John Carmarmac on a near lethal dose
of cocaine.
Yeah, that one works every time.
a skill issue, man. You got to just be
better at using the AI, says guy who
doesn't know how to program.
Funny
Google down 200 bill because Jeff Dean
leave
us as well, right?
I could never be better at programming
than AI. Absolutely you can, dude. Finn
is an un like Finn who is our intern is
an undergrad and he is absolutely
kicking ass.
You just think that the things are
better than they are. Like
the AI, okay, it's superhuman at some
things, but it's like generally very
stupid. It's not AGI. It's like very
very narrow intelligence presented as
though it is broad intelligence.
Like this is the type of stuff we build
with RL, right? We train agents that are
superhuman on lots of tasks. We just
don't pretend that they're general.
He got demoted.
I don't think that's true. What's your
source on that?
time investment to reward ratio, but to
get the job done is a well, what do you
care about?
Like
I mean if you're just typing things into
the AI without any knowledge of what
you're doing like it might feel like
you're getting things done but you al
you ultimately have to recognize that
you're adding absolutely no value to
anything whatsoever.
And um there might be some jobs you can
do now with that but longer term there
aren't going to be any whatsoever
because like you have no value if you
have no knowledge. Simple as that.
So, I mean, it's really up to you if you
want to take the time to learn what's
actually going on,
understand the process, if you enjoy the
engineering or not.
And if you don't, I would strongly
encourage you to find, you know, find
another line of work that you do enjoy
because you're not going to have a good
time if uh
if you don't want to learn some of the
fundamentals. And I don't mean like
stuffy classroom for four years, learn
the fundamentals. You can actually learn
the ropes pretty quick and it's a lot of
fun too.
Build a couple puffer without like just
letting the AI do it for you.
Few hundred lines of code. Very very
simple first year of systems level
concepts involved. You learn some
higherf engineering. You build something
pretty cool.
Same techniques are applied everywhere.
like the
theoretical stuff. Well, the thing with
CS that's tough about the theory is um
the code ultimately runs on a computer.
So I mean unless like you mean really
really theoretical stuff like you just
want to be uh like you want to be a
professor in theoretical computer
science
where you improve um like algorithmic
complexity bounds or whatnot.
Then you need to know how the computer
works.
Well, what do you mean? Aren't the
models going to get better?
Is the question like should I not learn
to program because the models are just
going to do it for me? Like in that
case, why learn theoretical computer
science because the models will just do
that as well,
right?
Like why learn anything if the models
are just going to do
I think we're almost done here.
We'll see whether this if this is
stable. I'm pretty happy.
I mean, literally Sutton just tweeted
the other day that his uh mo his work
was not primarily driven by math.
Yeah, I mean because what happens most
of the time is the theoretical thing
that you can prove is very very very
weak and then you go try it on every
problem you can get your hands on and it
beats everything else. Right.
Why? It's not B. You can't just make you
can't make progress purely theoretical.
Are you hiring?
Eh, sort of not really. Um,
so our work is contract based and when
we expand contracts, we typically pull
people that we have worked with before
either professionally or on one of the
larger open-source club projects within
Puffer.
We are not yet doing full-time positions
uh because we are not taking funding and
as such growth has to be organic with
contracts
and contract based work doesn't give you
like the full-time fixed salary
guarantee
at least not yet.
We will probably expand a little bit
once we get a bit bigger. Um, those
people will come from
most likely the top contributors and
people who have done very impressive
things around the project.
Definitely won't be randoms.
Um,
but we don't intend to get very large
for sure. Like I don't think Popper
needs to be that big in order to
accomplish a lot of stuff.
goal is kind of to have a small focused
private lab.
Though presumably some of the other
things we do around Puffer we might hire
people for.
Eventually we'll be doing dedicated
applications with Puffer and we might
hire externally for that.
Yeah, dude. You can't replace No, you
can't replace Matt Mole with Hatamar.
That's not like That's nuts. Make a
hedge fund. No, thank you.
one of the last things I'd like to be
doing with my life. Thank you very much.
the model like
what was that model? What model, dude?
What? Oh, hatamard.
I mean that just has such like that's a
weak pointwise interaction, right?
Doesn't get you a transformation.
applications buffer. The thing I care
most about is scientific simulation.
Definitely won't be the only thing we do
commercially, but that's what I care
most about long term.
And then it's all direct product.
That works dramatically differently.
There's a reduction operation, my guy.
It's not direct product. Actually,
the difference like it literally that
turns into a lo a set of local matals if
you unroll it. Like
same thing.
You can if if you act if you really
write it out, you can turn it into a
you can turn it into a really really
bloated block multiplication with shared
weights.
Are you related to Adam Sandler?
No.
What
you want to know? The really funny part
about that question. I know that that's
a name I should know, but I don't even
know who that is.
Who is this actor?
that's not me being a Zoomer, Kvert.
That's just me not watching movies ever.
I genuinely don't watch movies like
ever.
Like I don't watch TV series. I don't
watch movies. cuz I just don't.
though.
I'm pretty sure the last movie I watched
was when I was still a PhD student.
I watched um
A Few Good Men
randomly
and I think be before that I don't even
know. I probably watched less than five
movies in the last like eight years or
something.
All right, I got a few minutes and then
I got to go. Hopefully uh we get this
test in.
But that's basically it. I'm kind of
just hanging out at this point.
Rock 45. It's well, okay, this is not
it's running a long experiment, but at
the very least, excluding experiment
times, um it's at the very least faster.
So if all the models are going to give
me a wrong answer anyways, at least I
get the answer faster.
generally a much better job of if you're
doing small scope changes of keeping me
in the loop. Codeex just takes too long
and then it comes up like it does if you
try to just say, "Oh, it's smarter so I
can let it go do things on its own,
right?" Like, no, it just does dumb
[ __ ] anyways.
So, for my liking,
this is better.
Honestly, the best thing they could do
is if they just made the thing run 5x
faster. That'd be the best upgrade for
my for uh for my
Come on.
We got it.
4.6 is supposed to be tomorrow. I I
would sincerely hope that they don't
like if it is slower, I sincerely would
hope that they don't just replace four
or five entirely. Okay.
wait a second. I know where this is.
You're in Palo Alto.
Uh, Paulo Alto, not SF.
I am in the Bay Area.
Not permanently. I'm usually here in the
summer though.
Looks like we're not going to have this
done in time. So, um I think we're going
to call it here because I need to get to
dinner. I'll probably run some idle
experiments over the next day or so
while I do some other stuff.
Uh let me do quick summary for y'all. So
uh the big thing that we find at the
moment right is that there is a major
issue with how PO deals with momentum
based optimizers that includes atom but
also muon and this is at least a major
part of the reason that high sample
reuse is unstable. This causes a lot of
hyperparameter jank and in turn causes a
lot of uh difficulty in sweeping hypers
and getting consistent params. So major
major core issue with the algorithm.
We found a couple references that
addressed different portions of this
problem, but nothing fully solves it.
Um, I implemented a couple different
things. We got some lukewarm results.
There were some pretty major conflating
factors with how PO does its clipping
and that not really preventing you from
making bad updates. So we now have TRPO
temporarily. uh TRPO is very very slow.
So obviously we're not going to use that
but temporarily we use TRPO
in order to isolate the problem down to
just the handling of momentum. We're
going to apply fixes here. We're going
to port those fixes up to Muan. We're
going to make sure that we can basically
run an unlimited number of optim steps
and uh never collapse our policy under
TRPO. Then keeping the same momentum
changes, we're going to go back to PO
and get it to be stable there. And then
we're going to ship a brand new fancy
optim algorithm that solves all of the
problems and is no longer janky
hellscape RL that we've been dealing
with for the past decade.
That is the plan. However, uh that plan
is going to be interrupted because I've
had a good day professionally before
this and it is time to go celebrate with
margaritas. So, I will see you all
around. I may or may not stream
tomorrow. We will see. I'll definitely
will be back early next week. I'll keep
iterating on this and uh yeah, we'll see
how this goes. If you are new around
here, Puffer is entirely open source.
You can train agents in your browser.
Well, you can watch agents in your
browser, train them on your laptop in
seconds.
It's all here at puffer.ai. I stream all
the dev for this project. Pretty much
all the dev. If you want to help us out
for absolutely free, start the repo.
Actually helps more than you'd expect.
Discord's where all the dev happens.
Lots of helpful people here if you want
to get involved.
There is actually meaningful stuff you
can do with like very very very basic
systems. I mean first undergrad course
in systems level knowledge. We got lots
of demos here. You can follow me on X
for more educational content.